so when them saying that to you did they
say anyhow name names us to husa but oh
you'll never make money at this or that
fool you know what are you gonna do in
the meantime support yourself did you
ever get that speech and how did you
handle that I never got that are you I
just got from from we know one relative
you know and and he was just concerned
you but I was like I don't think you get
it yeah I mean I yeah I don't think no
one so that's me um I think at least my
family knew and close friends knew that
that maybe I'm not completely stable and
that I was moving forward no matter what
so there was there is no room for
failure so they I think they knew that
even if they were gonna like gay this
isn't gonna work out I was gonna go one
ear and out the other yeah that was kind
of our mantra through the whole project
was work moving forward no matter what
yeah really good for sure I was like
nothing nothing saw this town just and
whatever happens happens and we'll make
do with what we have at the very least
we'll learn a ton of stuff yeah that
that was a huge that was a driving
factor um and and one of the beginning
meetings that one of the first means
that Jonah had but once we decided to
make the film you know that was those
integral part of the process like no
matter what we have to grow we have to
learn and if we're not growing learning
and having fun and this is another
pointless yeah because there's it's just
way too much stress there's just too
much going on so what's the best advice
to well me friends family college
professors but you know maybe they do
either your best interest at heart they
don't want to see you you know getting a
ton of dead or whatever it is or spend
time but you know that you have to do
this for you whatever the outcome is
just thank them and smile I think I
would listen to them you mean I would
definitely know for sure I would listen
to what they're saying because I
it's there's something to be learned and
thank them for being Frank yeah and not
trying to be like oh boy sure that's the
right idea you know mm-hmm because I
mean even once people have seen parts of
the film no I don't get that I don't
like that it's not for everybody so we
already know that but why didn't you
like it or like what what can I learn
from them possibly as I did make me
better understand what went wrong or
maybe nothing went wrong but at least
I'm learning something or at least
considering something that's more what
we wanted to entertain consideration not
that something is right over all yeah
but yeah I would say definitely listen
to people and then do what you want to
do if you think you want to roll the
dice and all the dice and I knew I also
listened to wisdom still yeah because
yeah they were definitely there are
definitely times during the shoot that
I'm going full-steam forward and
thankfully Joe first or another or
somebody else in the production was like
dude this is this is not going to work
and then we then we change directions
but um you know it's it's also it I
would say in addition to listening
listening to what other people have to
say so surround yourself with people
that you trust and that are going to
support your vision or work together in
order to achieve that so so not people
that are totally negative and not people
who are just told yes people yeah yeah
there isn't balance for sure yeah I mean
you want somebody that's going to say
hey I what it wouldn't it would this be
better maybe you know and it's great to
have a marketplace of ideas like that in
any project so yeah but you also going
to many of the fighters xiii can get
like you're crazy you go yeah definitely
to rain
and keep the people that you trust close
and games or to a limited number or
lease its Craig's that you don't trust
themselves okay oh my god make sure no I
what I'm saying is you definitely want
to have a limited you're clearly going
to need this is the ultimate
collaborative art in my opinion so
you're going to get a lot of people in
order to pull off whatever crazy idea
that you have but i would say that
nucleus people has to be small that you
really trust that are that are really
going to push for the project to be
complete and allow you to pursue the
vision that you intended that you
intended for so and just you know just
to believe in it rather than just
participate in it you know that's that's
that's that's huge advice for other
people because a lot of people just are
going to be along because of someone's
making a film and there were definitely
a lot of phone calls that we got along
throughout the process about people
wanting to help out in different ways
and hey i think you have to be careful
because a lot of people aren't going to
put the same type of effort that you are
or your your your little strong nucleus
cool yeah wouldn't have to have some
relevant skills as well you know yeah
having to production that is you know
yeah that's true
you